bonjour messieurs dames aujourd'hui on
se retrouve pour une vidéo un petit peu
spécial qui va répondre à une question
que vous me posez depuis une éternité
les gens gardent le tacot sa carte
graphique est un petit aller alors on va
y répondre tout de suite ces partis
juste après je vous explique le petit
jeu concours
suivez moi mais on n'avait pas me suivre
puisque ça va faire la cote alors là on
se retrouve donc devant mon ordi
complètement éventré en lui-même sa
polar que je vais leur greffer après
bien évidemment les associations pour
sécurité d'ordinateurs calmez-vous ok
c'était une blague notamment à ce que je
veux faire tellement beau bref alors je
vais tout vous dire un petit peu un
parent ce que j'ai au niveau de mon
processeur c'est un quadcore 3,3 giguère
mon niveau de cette petite aire que vous
voyez juste la mort dit allume est
d'ailleurs faux pas qui touche les
composants ne jamais faire ça donc c'est
un aveu tv donc une petite carte que
j'ai vu à noël pour 86 euros je crois il
ya deux ans ensuite au niveau de la
carte mère c'est une asus gigabyte ga
768 xp ud3p sa marque et sur au niveau
de la nuque c'est une 750 watts
donc c'est pour alimenter un petit peu
tout brille c'est maintenant l'élément
le plus important pour un gamer la carte
graphique et ben ouais pour ceux qui ne
sauraient pas c'est là qu'un graphique
qui fait essentiellement la puissance
d'un pc gamer alors la mienne c'est une
assiette sera des ouvrages 17 1970 ce
jeu d'échangé a vraiment pas longtemps
justement je me suis un peu intéressé au
sujet voir des comparatifs et c'est
parce que vous savez il ya une grande
guerre entre les cartes nvidia donc
nvidia gtx machin et entre celles-ci d
amd c'est le conte des puces amd
donc bon cette guerre moi je suis pas
trop pour moi nvidia pour des
performances égales reste quand même
plus cher alors c'est vraiment que mon
avis c'est pas la peine de lâcher un
gros plus rouge pour la vidéo si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord vous pouvez gravir
votre avis en commentaire moi je
complètement open justement c'est ce que
j'ai constaté que bon les cartes nvidia
sont peut-être je crois plus instables
ou quoi sur certains jeux mais au final
quand je sors à les deux les deux sort
des pilotes pour que la carte pour que
les performances de la carte soit
vraiment au maximum en fonction du jeu
qui sort qu elles soient les plus
adaptées les plus poussées et plus
optimisé tout simplement
alors donc moi j'ai préféré prendre
cette carte il parce qu'elle est quand
même moins cher que l'équivalent chez
nvidia alors bon les gros avantage parce
que pour ceux qui savent pas même si
vous prenez une m17 1970 sera des mois
j'ai 7077 les performances sont toutes
les mêmes à peu près chez les cartes
mais à chaque fois on fait le
constructeur change vous avez ce qu'on
le comme constructeur vous avez saphir
bas à chier est ce vous avez gigabit et
c'est alors pourquoi moi j'ai pris à
chiès pascal chier c'est en fait pour
moi est vraiment une grosse différence
déjà de base entre toutes les cartes
graphiques bon le design peut changer de
l'une à l'autre
mais pourquoi ils changent c'est surtout
lié au système de refroidissement même
si la structure peut parfois changer
mais les performances sur le sujet elle
a way qui n'a jamais senti une odeur de
cramé en posant les performances tomber
un petit peu trop forte
là le système de refroidissement c'est
le ice cube avec ce club à la glace et q
comme comme tu au carré bref où elle
fait pas de bruit parce que oui et le
système de refroidissement est liée
aussi enfin c'est ce qui fait un peu si
la carte fait du bruit au nom système de
refroidissement est super génial gerbe
liste aix à gauche c'est mieux là vous
pourrez pousser les performances de la
carte graphique en ce qu en ce qu'on
appelle l'os et l'overclocking
c'est à dire ça consiste à augmenter un
petit peu les fréquences de la carte pas
trop hein vous jetez pas sur l'occasion
pour ceux qui font ces vertus et surtout
les problèmes n'ont en fait gaffe parce
que ça peu cramé vite fait faut pas trop
pousser loin non plus mais pour ce
combat mois en boîtier assez bien qui
refroidit quand même vraiment bien quand
même des fois un ventirad un truc comme
ça ici la guerre froide aient encore
plus ben vous pouvez tout simplement
augmenter un peu les frais quand ça va
augmenter légèrement les performances de
la carte par un truc de ouf vous n'avez
pas gagné à des performances de malades
mais quand même c'est toujours ça moi
c'est sur moi je les fais écouter ça
passe à peu s'est passé crème
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai pris une
chaise pour le système de
refroidissement voilà c'est tout pour la
carte graphique ya ensuite au niveau des
disques durs bon disque dur basique ya
pas de marques ou je sais pas trop quoi
bon je pense que si ça serait ça les
performances évaluant tours par minute
je crois sur les disques durs
alors moi c'est un
un bon pas énorme tours par minute je
sais même pas il date façon ce disque
d'or sur qu'est ce que vous voulez donc
ouais intérêt pour ce disque dur ssd de
60 gigas et gérard nos disques durs
aussi de 1 tera donc ça me fait deux
terrains en disque dur plus de disques
durs portables de 500 giga chacun donc
on a trois terrains et le sld sur lequel
on installe les jeux etc pour qu'il
tourne plus vite et ça soit goût de haut
niveau du boîtier je sais plus la
référence mais elle est dans la
description bon le seul truc que j'aime
bien avec ce boîtier c'est que juste là
en fait là il ya un petit bouton vous
allez voir que quand je remonte le
bouton écoutez bien voilà je sens déjà
plus d afrique il vient vers moi
à savoir que la vitesse d'éviter des
ventilos pardon elle augmente donc par
exemple dès que je lance un jeu qui
bouffent des pères par peur que ça
chauffe trop je mets ventilo à fond et
dès que je suis pépère sur l'ordi où
jouent un jeu pas trop gourmand je le
remets au minimum pour que ça fasse
vraiment zéro bruit et c'est vraiment
très très good pour ce qui est des prix
je voulais dire sur l'un qui
s'intéressent un peu la carte graphique
donc cenaci smd radio 7970 donc elle est
vraiment goût de moi perso où je suis
satisfait d'un suis satisfait tout donc
je crois qu'elle est à 400 fin donc je
ne regardais aller dans les 380 de
jérôme et au pire ou tel modèle band
sous le 7950 où elle est moins chère à
bois dans les 330 je pense vont
s'enrichir pour une carte graphique mais
voilà les pc gamer ça coûte quand même
la peau du cul mais en tout cas pour
ceux qui veulent un je vous conseille
vraiment si vous avez déjà un écran au
clavier/souris de prendre un pc fixe
parce que par exemple pour un pc fixe de
1300 euros vous aurez des performances
largement mieux qu'un pc portable à 1300
euros
parce que dans le pc portable ou
n'oublie pas qu'il ya l'écran puis c'est
plus petit c'est pas c'est même pas les
mêmes cartes graphiques qu'il ya dedans
parce que c'est des spéciales plus petit
pour les portables etc
les noms sont pas les mêmes pour des
paroles pour des performances
il ya par exemple donc voilà 380 euros
celle-ci vous allez en dessous 320 4 au
niveau du processeur je crois qui coûte
combien
3 il devait dans les 180 mon processeur
votre façon vous checkez un rocker vous
regardez sur des forums
un peu ce qui est le mieux dans le
domaine gaming pour pas trop cher vous
avez ici une alim
alors c'est le
le mec qui m'a dépanné donc c'est une
750 watts pour tenir parce que oui
n'oubliez pas plus vous avez des des
cargos une carte graphique folle ou à un
processeur fou quoi plus vous faut une
alim qui qui alimente tout le bordel
quoi sinon ça risque de surchauffe et où
on aime d'abîmer les produits s'ils sont
pas à s'alimenter
c'est une bonne âme ses 250 watts alors
je sais même pas je n'aime pas cette
marque mais elle tient bien pour l'ombre
pas le charme bien au niveau oui donc de
la carte mère elle doit coûter dans les
110 euros je pense ou 120 120 euros 130
quelque chose du genre
et puis le boîtier lui doit être les 60
70 voilà tout et puis c'est au niveau de
tous à disque dur bon c'est classe i ma
caméra vient de se couper toute seule je
pense que ça voulait dire ferme ta
gueule lucas tu parles trop donc on va
s'arrêter là juste oui je disais pour
les disques durs ça se vend en tours par
minute ça peut augmenter la vitesse par
exemple le chargement dans les jeux
genre dans league of legend ou des
choses du genre
et puis voilà ça à peu près tout ce que
j'avais à vous dire sur cet ordi
tu voi à l'écouté je parle vite je parle
beaucoup maintenant je pense qu'on va
passer à ce qui vous intéresse à savoir
le concours mais qu'avons nous donc
aujourd'hui à gagner alors cette fois le
concours diab plusieurs types de choses
à gagner pendant cette fois on va un peu
de favoriser les joueurs pc les gamer
accord pc parce que oui bon j'ai
toujours fait gagner des consoles des
jeux sur sur consoles mais bon un moment
je pense qu'il faut quand même tu peux
donner des choses aux joueurs pc alors
aujourd'hui je propose des codes pour
gagner donc 20 ans agger et 20 pas le
choc
in fine art et le tout nouveau nom
qu'est cassé baudelle ramé gabon ultra
je vous le dis alors je dis pas ça pour
un effectif
il ya aussi un jeu console à gagner
n'importe quel au choix d'être des bons
d'achat à gagner donc 50 bond de 15,0
sur l'a7 1950 et sans bon d'achat de 10
euros sur l'a7 1805
donc c'est quand même la preuve en
classe et 1950 mais c'est bien alors
pour ces bons d'achat ces mêmes
principes que le ch temps s'est mis à
disposition c'est à dire que si jamais
il dans vos projets vous avez acheté un
pc gamer vous faites vous même vous
prenez une machine 7950 ou 7850 époque
prenez un des bons d'achat ils sont
limités quand même c'est que quand on
les a utilisés
il y en a plus mais bon voilà ça fait
toujours 10 euros 15 euros gradins 10
euros 15 euros et gagné à savoir deux ou
trois grecs c'est pas bien quoi parce
que oui de toute mesure en y maintenant
et voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à gagner
pour le concours enfin si on peut dire
c'est tout alors pour participer ça sert
à rien de mettre en commentaire je
participe pour les règles du jeu ont
changé bon vous l'avez vu bien beaucoup
en avant maintenant en fait c'est le
bouton plus pour voir tous les
commentaires ya plus page on peut plus
vraiment trouver tel ou tel nombreux im
10 à 10,8 de commentaire alors qu'on
faut aller sur le site de guerre rognac
vous rentrez un petit peu vous info vous
répondre à deux questions très très très
très dur vous allez voir si vous avez
suivi la présentation de mon envie de
briller répondent single de toute façon
bien vous mettrez tous dans les
commentaires la réponse pour le concours
parce que vous êtes solidaires
dès que tout le monde ait les mêmes
chances de gagner bons deux buts aux
actes du groupe herbert précédent m goal
aaa
donc voilà le lien du concours et dans
la description alors vous inquiétez pas
y en a pour deux minutes à tout craché
la fin du concours sera le 15 avril et
les résultats seront publiés sur le site
de gamme onac donc le 16 avril mais vous
inquiétez pas je vous lis on crée du
lien sur twitter facebook et même de
bala dans la description pour le
concours sera finie et on se retrouve de
suite là dans quelques secondes sur
bioshock infinite c'est parti
[Musique]